Hey everyone, it's Mike from Orderflows
here, and in this video I'll be talking
about my favorite, my A+ uh
order flow trade setup. It's super easy
to see. You know, if you're looking at a
footprint like this, this is just your
normal bid ask footprint, right? This is
where a lot of traders start from. And
to be honest, you know, for a lot of
traders it's difficult to read. I mean,
you got delta numbers, you've got
imbalances, you've got points of
control. Um you know, and especially if
you're newer to order flow, trying to
understand, you know, what you're
looking at and you know, it is hard,
especially if, you know, you're not
familiar or don't again, don't
understand how the market works in terms
of um
you know, aggressive buying, aggressive
selling versus passive buying, passive
selling, um what absorption is in the
order flow, uh turning points, etc. And
you know, I created the Orderflows
Trader software to help traders
understand what they're looking at. And
one of the tools that we have in the
Orderflows Trader software is what we
call value area absorption. Okay, so
when you're looking at your normal
footprint, right, you just you again, a
lot of times we don't know what we don't
know. And we have this little setting in
here, it's called value area absorption.
And and to enable it, all what you have
to do is you enable the value area
itself. Um you know, we have it as a
template, so you know, if you were to
just load it, it's very simple. You do
value area absorption right here, and
it's going to plot the value area
absorption, the ones that matter. Now,
you know, we all should understand what
absorption is in the market, right? It's
it's where buyers
um are stepping into the market to
support the market or sellers are coming
into offer resistance in the market. And
where's it going to be most effective?
Again, at potential turning points in
the market. So,
with that in mind, right? So, you're
going to see some bars have bullish
absorption. That's these
blue areas in the bar. That's bullish
ones. The bearish one is the red.
The red.
The red. the red. Blue is bullish, very
visual, very easy to see. Now, again,
[clears throat] all what you got to do
is you got to focus in on swing highs
and swing lows. So, here we got, you
know, this is the low of the day. We got
a a bullish order flow absorption taking
place, and we have this nice rally up to
where where we have
bearish absorption coming in, right?
This is coming in at a swing high. You
know, people will say, "Well, here you
got a swing high. This isn't this
bearish?" Okay, but again, you know, we
were just trading here not too long ago.
So, you know, does that qualify as a
swing high? You If you want to, you
know, potentially you could short it
there. Okay, but then it came right back
with another bullish
value area absorption right there. Right
here, you got a nice swing low. You got
a bullish signal coming in. Here, you
got a bearish one kind of at this swing
high.
Okay, now this is a euro currency. This
is an eight range chart. And you know,
whether you're using a minute base
chart, etc. Um, you know, it's all good.
You'll you'll see these things come in,
and you know,
here you got bear Whoops.
You got bearish coming in right here.
Another bearish one here at the swing
high.
Swing low, bullish.
Bullish at this swing low.
Bearish at this swing high. And when you
add, you know, sort of other forms of
order flow analysis to it,
okay, such as, you know, what what would
you want to add? Well, you could add the
exhaustion print set up, right? You
know, I talk about this exhaustion
print. Here, you got a nice bearish
exhaustion print coming in here. But the
way I like to trade these, right, is I'm
looking for the abandoned ones where
we're not trading into it in the next
bar. I find those to be very very
effective. Here, we got one right on the
open, and the market just sold right off
from that open.
Okay?
Um, you know, getting back, you know,
over here, you don't have the exhaustion
print on this low.
Okay?
But, it is abandoned. I know this market
is starting to move away from this area
where you have that absorption.
Okay?
Now,
let's let's sort of flip the script here
and take a look at another market.
So, a question I get a lot is, you know,
can you use order flow on sort of a
higher time frame like 5-minute chart or
even 10-minute or 15-minute chart? And,
you know, I always believe that order
flow is best used as soon as, you know,
something bullish or bearish appears,
you know, so you can take advantage of
it. But, this is a 5-minute euro
currency chart, okay? And,
you know, just make it smaller here, we
can just see these swing areas.
Right? Swing low.
Bullish order flow absorption, rallies
up to where? Bearish order flow
absorption, sells off to where? Down
here, new low, where you got bullish
order flow absorption. I mean, you can't
you know, I mean, I don't want to say
you can't make this stuff up, but, you
know, look at this right here.
Bearish order flow exhaustion absorption
with the exhaustion print of one as
well, right up there.
You know, it it's just
really nice to see because that's what
happens at swing highs and swing lows.
Just going back,
you know, I don't know if you'd call
this here as a swing high.
You know, it is a little bit higher than
this other most recent high. And, you
can see over the next
couple of bars, nice sell-off down to
new lows.
Okay?
Um, what else we got here? Let's just go
back a little bit further. Oops, that's
too much. Um,
you know, this is coming right after the
swing low was made right here.
Where is that? I'll just draw it out
here.
You know,
this was the low here. This one came in
a bar afterwards. So,
um
let's see, anything else here?
Again, this sort of coming in after that
low is made. Right up here at this high
of the day, right here.
Again, you know, you got nice
imbalance reversals taking place here.
Here.
You know, more buying imbalances. Market
starts selling off down to new lows. So,
you know, this is the
one of my favorite setups, right? Just
looking for absorption in the order
flow.
Um you know, especially specifically in
the value areas. Not everybody is
looking at the value areas in the bar,
you know, and
it's nothing complex, right? The value
area is where 70% of the volume is
taking place. So, imagine, if you're at
the high and you're looking at the value
area where the majority of the volume,
the 70% of the volume is taking place,
and it shows sign of absorption
at the high of the day, yeah, that's
probably that's a nice bearish sign.
Just as if you're at
you know, trading, you know, at the low
of the day or swing low, right? It
doesn't have to be the low of the day.
Swing low with bullish absorption, low
of the day with bullish absorption,
right? Trades right up to swing high
with bearish absorption,
right? From the swing low to the swing
high, back down to the a new swing low
in the in the low of the day.
All right, guys. So, you know, again,
you know, in the
you know, not to promote my own
software, but, you know, the Order Flow
Suite Trader software is the only
software that will identify the bullish
absorption
in the
bar and the bearish absorption. Bullish,
bullish, bullish to bearish, bearish,
bearish right here, just like that.
Okay?
Sorry, guys. Thanks, and I'll catch you
guys on another video.